arrest has been made in connection with
a New Hampshire couple found dead in
Texas adam curtis williams was located
in mexico and taken to houston last
night he was arrested for felony theft
but not for the murder of the couple
James and Michelle Butler Meg Oliver is
just back from Texas and has been the
only Network reporter covering this case
meg why do you think why do officials
think Williams may be involved good
morning well Anthony the only key piece
of evidence linking him to the murder of
James Michelle Butler was a photo of
Williams and a woman taken at the
us-mexico border that photo showed that
33 year old Williams behind the wheel of
the murdered couple's truck the arrest
warrant accuses him of felony auto theft
Mexican authorities also detained the
woman seen sitting next to him
identified as Amanda NAVAIR they say she
was in the country illegally the
butler's remains were found October 27th
in shallow graves on Padre Island
south of Houston last year they went on
a dream road trip living out of their RV
a member of the butler's family tells
CBS News they're relieved Williams has
been caught he was arrested last night
in Houston then driven back to Kleber
County Jail where he remains this
morning a news conference is scheduled
for later this morning and we're
expecting to hear more information of
course we're going to be monitoring you
know right now the details are just for
felony theft but it sure doesn't look
good to be driving the vehicle of a
couple that's been murdered that look
good and buried we should say squatches
are the safety of doing that I mean a
lot of people rent rvs make that trip it
is a dream trip for many yes I make
thank you very much